Atentos a esta pregunta, ¿quién diríais
que es el mayor aliado de Estados Unidos?
¿Canadá? ¿Tal vez Reino Unido? ¿Puede que
Israel? No es una pregunta nada fácil y
desde luego depende de qué preguntemos y
a quién preguntemos; pero hay un país
que ha sumado muchos puntos en los
últimos años,
hasta tal punto que para los
republicanos hoy ya es el mayor aliado
de Estados Unidos.
El mejor amigo, por encima de cualquier
otro país, y no, no es Canadá, ni Reino unido,
es... Australia, el país del surf,
los canguros y la ópera de Sidney.
¿Sorprendidos? Pues no deberíais estarlo
si tenemos en cuenta, amigos de VisualPolitik,
que Australia es el único
país del mundo que ha luchado con
Estados Unidos en todas sus grandes
contiendas: en las dos guerras mundiales,
en Corea, en Vietnam, en la Guerra del
Golfo, en Afganistán, en Irak y
también ahora en las operaciones contra
el Estado Islámico.
Vamos, casi podemos decir que para el
Pentágono
los australianos son lo que Luka Modric
es al Real Madrid, es un jugador que puede
pasar desapercibido pero siempre es
titular indiscutible.
Pues bien, pese a todo esto, el pasado 28
de enero de 2017
Donald Trump le colgó el teléfono al
mismísimo Primer Ministro de Australia,
Malcolm Turnbull,  y no sólo eso, antes de
mandarle a paseo y colgarle el teléfono
Trump le acusó de querer exportar terroristas
a Estados Unidos. Y todo por un acuerdo de
poco peso al que habían llegado los dos
países, un acuerdo que implicaba que
Estados Unidos acogería a  1.250
refugiados, pero... esa es otra historia que
contaremos en otro vídeo. Sí, puede parecer
un suceso anecdótico pero ha
provocado que muchos australianos se
pregunten si no es ya la hora de echarle
un poco de hielo a tanto amiguismo.
Pues bien, todo esto nos ha hecho
hacernos unas cuantas preguntas ¿cómo de
importante es Australia para Estados
Unidos? ¿Tiene sentido que Trump le
colgara el teléfono a su mayor aliado?
¿Qué consecuencias puede tener? Pues bien,
vayamos a verlo.
No es nada nuevo, y desde luego todos
aquellos que nos seguís habitualmente lo
sabéis bien: el mundo ha cambiado y
tanto el peso del poder político como
del poder económico se están
desplazando a toda velocidad hacia Asia.
Aproximadamente para 2020
más de la mitad de toda la economía y
de toda la población mundial se
concentrarán en este continente y desde
luego la emergencia de China como una
nueva superpotencia es todo un hecho.
Hasta hace poco este era el mapa del
mundo más común ¿verdad? Pues a partir
de ahora veremos cada vez más este otro.
Como veis, Europa deja de estar en el
centro del mundo para pasar a estar en
una esquina.
Desde luego en la práctica esto no es
más que una anécdota pero no me
negaréis que es todo un símbolo de
cómo están cambiando las cosas, ¿no os parece?
- "¿Está diciendo que Alemania
no está donde creó? Nada está donde
cree ¿donde está?
buena pregunta.
No hay duda, el siglo XXI
será el tiempo de la gran
transformación de Asia. En este siglo
veremos a muchos países convertirse en
auténticas potencias mundiales, porque,
ojo cuando hablamos de Asia
no sólo hablamos de China, hablamos
también de países como Indonesia,
Filipinas y por supuesto la India.
Precisamente, por este motivo el anterior
presidente de los Estados Unidos, Barack
Obama, decidió apostar fuerte por Asia y
convertir a este continente en la
prioridad número uno de la diplomacia
estadounidense.
Y es que, precisamente bajo esta
circunstancias, es donde Australia, de
repente se ha convertido en un amigo muy
valioso. Pero... ¿hasta dónde llega la
amistad entre Estados unidos y Australia?
Veamoslo.
En noviembre de 2011, Barack Obama y la
entonces Primer Ministro de Australia,
Julia Gillard, firmaron un tratado
militar que supuso llevar la
cooperación en defensa entre ambos
países a una nueva dimensión. Casi
podemos decir que con este acuerdo,
amigos, daba comienzo todo un noviazgo en
materia militar entre Estados Unidos y
Australia.
De hecho, fijaros como describió el
New York Times este acuerdo:
Pero, ¿qué implicaba realmente este acuerdo?
De entrada, gracias al tratado firmado entre
Australia y Estados Unidos, la potencia
norteamericana puede desplegar en
Australia una fuerza de combate que se
irá incrementando progresivamente hasta
alcanzar los 2.500 soldados
pertenecientes al Cuerpo de Marines, es
decir, el cuerpo de combate que tiene la
misión de desplegarse rápidamente en
caso de conflicto.
Pero, ésta sólo es
una parte muy limitada de la historia,
porque lo cierto es que desde entonces
la colaboración entre ambos países no
ha dejado de crecer y crecer, hasta
el punto que hoy para Washington la
relación con su socio australiano se ha
convertido casi en imprescindible.
Porque, amigos de VisualPolitik,
no sólo se trata de los marines,
los Estados Unidos quieren convertir a este
país en la base de operaciones es clave
para sus actividades en el Océano
Pacífico y también en el Índico. Para
que os hagáis una idea
Estados Unidos quiere tener acceso a
pistas de aterrizaje en el norte del
país, quiere desplegar en suelo
australiano bombarderos b2 y b52,  quiere
también fijar cerca de Perth, en el
extremo occidental de Australia, una
enorme base naval para su flota de
portaaviones y submarinos nucleares.
Y más, Estados Unidos también tiene
intención de situar aquí centros de
vigilancia aérea, instalaciones de
alerta de lanzamientos de misiles e,
incluso, quiere alquilar parte de estas islas,
las Islas Cocos, un remoto enclave en el
Índico de soberanía australiana.
Y estaréis pensando ¿cómo? ¿Cómo? ¿Alquilar
unas islas? ¿Para qué diantres quiere
Estados Unidos unas islas perdidas en el
Índico? Pues la respuesta es clara:
Estados Unidos quiere situar en las Islas
Cocos aviones de vigilancia de largo
alcance, drones armados y en caso de
guerra utilizar este archipiélago como
centro de despegue para sus
bombarderos. Y ¿sabéis qué? Esto no acaba
aquí, porque por supuesto Estados Unidos
también quiere mejorar la integración
entre su ejército y las fuerzas armadas
australianas, para en caso de necesidad
estar listos para operar conjuntamente.
Hasta el momento la parte australiana ha
sido muy receptiva a las intenciones de
Estados Unidos y ya se han dado pasos de
gigante.
De hecho, Australia ha lanzado en los
últimos años una gran renovación
de sus equipos militares.
Hablamos de contratos de compra de miles
y miles de millones de dólares, entre
los que por supuesto hay mucho material
estadounidenses. Por ejemplo, el
controvertido f-35 del que Australia se
ha comprometido a comprar 72 unidades,
que le van a costar, ni más ni menos, que
la fabulosa cifra de 17.000 millones de
dólares.
Ojo, hablamos de un país de poco más de
24 millones de habitantes,
así que no está nada mal. Por cierto,
así despegan los nuevos juguetes del
ejército australiano
Y con todo esto, puede que ahora lo que
os estéis preguntando es ¿Y por qué Australia?
Pues, por varias razones: primero, porque ambos
países son culturalmente muy cercanos y
como hemos visto antes ya han combatido
muchas veces juntos.
Segundo, porque Australia tiene un
enclave geográfico casi perfecto; se
encuentra entre el Pacífico y el
Índico a una distancia suficiente de
los enclaves calientes de Asia como para
poder realizar ataques o desplegar tropa
relativamente rápido.
Y por último un tercer factor decisivo,
Australia es, en estos momentos, un
importante proveedor de energía,
materias primas y alimentos para China.
En caso de conflicto o de tensiones
fuertes, el control de Australia podría
ser una primera ventaja para Estados Unidos
Pero ¿qué pasa con la otra parte?
¿Qué quieren los australianos? Pues,
básicamente, entienden que Estados Unidos es,
para ellos, una especie de póliza de seguro que les
garantiza su seguridad.
Sin embargo, empiezan a escucharse cada
vez más voces que no están muy de
acuerdo con esta tesis. Y desde luego, el
qué Trump le colgase el teléfono a su
Primer Ministro ha dado mucha energía a
este movimiento
China se ha convertido, con mucha
diferencia, en el mayor socio comercial
de Australia. Es el primer destino de sus
exportaciones,
el país de origen de muchos de los
inmigrantes que han llegado a esta isla-continente,
y, además, cada año son más
los chinos que llegan a hacer turismo o
estudiar.
Vamos, que los chinos suponen mucho
dinerito para los australianos y eso
tiene consecuencias.
Y, ojo, los menores
de 45 años se inclinaron claramente por
China, su país debía distanciarse de un
Estados Unidos liderado por Donald Trump.
En esta línea que básicamente
apuesta forma más China y menos Estados Unidos,
está por ejemplo Paul Keating,
un importante ex primer ministro del
que hablamos hace muy poco. Atentos a
cómo justifica su posición:
De momento, lo que sí que ha hecho
Australia es hacer muchos guiños al
gigante asiático. Por ejemplo, y para
disgusto de Washington,
el país decidió participar en el "Banco
Asiático de Inversión en
Infraestructuras" una institución liderada
por China y con la que Pekín quiere
incrementar su influencia en el
continente. Y desde el propio gobierno
australiano se ha dejado claro que China es
sobre todo una gran fuente de
oportunidades. Para colmo, últimamente
Estados Unidos no hace más que darle
disgustos a los australianos. Cuando, por
ejemplo, Donald Trump decidió tumbar
el TPP dejando fuera a Estados Unidos el
gobierno de Australia, que había sido un
firme partidario del tratado, no sólo
mostró su decepción sino que su
ministra de exteriores, Julie Bishop,
dijo que estaba estudiando incluso
sugerir al
resto de miembros que China ocupase el
puesto de Estados Unidos.
Por suerte para los estadounidenses aún
son muchos los lazos que protegen la
alianza con Australia de personajes como Donald Trump.
Australia y
Estados Unidos son política, cultural y
económicamente países muy similares.
Tanto, que no es extraño que a nivel
internacional se considere que Australia
es una prolongación del modo de vida, de
la identidad estadounidense, en Asia.
Y desde luego los australianos aún están
muy orgullosos de esta consideración:
Además, EEUU sigue, con diferencia,
siendo el mayor inversor en Australia.
Una inversión que por cierto supera,
atentos, los 500.000 millones de dólares.
También, el hecho de que China continúe
siendo una dictadura, es algo que genera
muchos recelos en Australia, donde muchos
no se fían de las intenciones de
Pekín.
En esta línea, el gobierno ha vetado
varias operaciones de inversores chinos
que querían comprar tierra en Australia.
Así que, bien, podemos decir que si algo
parece previsible es que hoy por hoy la
alianza con Estados Unidos va a
continuar, pero también que los
australianos son muy pragmáticos y
tienen muy claro que no quieren verse
afectados por una guerra de poder entre
China y Estados Unidos.
Bueno, y a todo esto, ¿tú qué piensas? ¿Crees
que Estados Unidos conseguirá a
pesar de Donald Trump sacar adelante todos
sus proyectos en Australia? ¿O por el
contrario China irá cobrando cada vez
más y más influencia? Y si Trump le
colgara el teléfono a tu país ¿cómo te
lo tomarías? Déjanos tu opinión en los
comentarios,
y como dice Simon, si te ha gustado
este vídeo
levanta esos pulgares dándole al botón
de la like. ¿Cómo? ¿Aún no sabes quién es
Simon? Bueno, no te preocupes porque
tiene remedio.
Haz click aquí y suscríbete a nuestro
canal en inglés para conocerle.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.